a vaccination milestone today here in  the u.s half of all american adults are  now  fully vaccinated in our country this  comes as madonna says its vaccine is  safe for kids between 12 and 17.  the company plans to ask regulators to  authorize the shots for  emergency use in that age group  meanwhile the search for the cause of  covid  continues the origins there is a new  report now  linking it back to a lab in wuhan china  the white house says it has been  searching for answers for months  an international investigation led by  the world health organization is  something that we've actually been  pressing for  for several months the u.s has called on  china to release all information related  to research activity at that lab  in wuhan